[Music]
[Applause]
the A4 mentioned Roger Bennett is on
tour Across the Nation during the World
Cup heading to Philadelphia and
Washington D.C tickets available now at
meninblazers.com and also pick up a copy
of his new book gods of soccer and he
joins us now on the program how excited
are you today oh Danny Patrick I feel
like we're at the semi-final
um part of the World Cup but somehow
we're only day four in it's definitely
four games a day it's doing for us it's
a grind oh there's a grind this one
grind of Wonder and Japan surprises
Germany today in the uh Axis Powers
Derby yes it was uh it's quite a shot
the whole traditional World Order is
being stood on its head today Japan
dumping Germany the tiny tiny residue of
englishness in me I think Dan I realizes
just that I do laugh out loud when
Germany lose yesterday oh Saudi Arabia
an astonishing moment Saudi Arabia
outplayed tournament favorites oh Lionel
Messi's Argentine it was like seeing a
16 seed like the retrievers just dumped
a number one seed it was an astonishing
thing Richard the retrievers if the
retrievers were slightly less cute and
like had autocratic underpinnings
um can there be a third one on Friday
can the mighty U.S Dan Patrick
our our team our team yeah why are you
even joking there's there's an influence
of humor in that when you say our team
but bloody hell do not let my accent
fool you I ride with Team America with
the same passion that Kenny Powers will
be cheering for America I imagine
Springsteen will Springsteen gave a crap
about football Dolly Parton definitely
all in on this young American team do
you hate England
do I hang in so that's a long
question which we don't have time for I
wrote an article for the Wall Street
Journal they asked me who am I cheering
for like as if it was like an anguish a
Sophie's Choice like oh my God this must
be healthier and it's really not it's
really not the England played the US
women in 2019 with Alex Morgan so drink
tea mime drinking tea and my God I threw
my eyes on tour then we're in Nashville
Tennessee and I threw my beer in the air
and screamed out loud just as long as
just as loudly as some of the
tennesseans who've been in that state
for for decades even you know families
have been there for for
multi-generations I'm from Liverpool
that's the story I'm from Liverpool we
hate England and Liverpool we wanted the
seed when I was a kid became the
Republic of Liverpool they they hate us
we hate them we're like Philadelphia on
steroids we're like we're they hate us
we hate them and so I always felt deeply
connected to America as a kid it's where
all the great ideas kind of came through
the port of Liverpool first and coming
here becoming American something I took
super seriously and anyway the short
answer
when Peters Morgan is on one side of an
argument
whatever it is
that he did with Ronaldo
did you see this interview with Ronaldo
if you're Ronaldo why do you do that
interview with Piers Morgan that's why I
don't understand I mean Ronaldo is like
Tom Brady
um in uh if you don't know who Ronaldo
is America he's like a bottle of Draco
on the war turned into human form an
elite footballer one of the greatest and
doubted and the things that Drew into
greatness were a selfishness a vanity a
deep deep focus and as he ages like Tom
Brady
um those same things the selfishness the
vanity have actually been quite
destructive he's had a great Club second
return to Manchester United which would
be like if Tom Brady suddenly went back
to the New England Patriots it's been a
disaster and he decided on the eve of
the World Cup to do an interview where
he wanted a crap on the club and he
decided to do a Piers Morgan Dan why did
why would he go because he wanted to
take that he wanted to be released he
got what he wanted
yeah and so and so did um and so did
peers God love he got mild relevance in
everywhere but we have serious things to
talk about in every region let's not
talk about that kind of that kind of
human blight on a day when England are
about to play the United States possibly
I think people are going to watch you'd
know this in my bubble it's been talked
about as one of the Great Moments for
football the day after Thanksgiving
we have a great time and it's not truly
competing with with the American
sporting calendar there's a sliver of
how you got a window you got a window of
opportunity viewing-wise I would think
this is what happens with us we buy in
oh this is the we got a young group all
or you know are we maybe maybe a World
Cup too soon here uh and then England
beats us 5-1 and then we go
that's what that's what we're worried
worse when Iran beats us again 1998. yes
right after the hostage uh crisis and
the president called up the team and
said America's expecting you to do your
duty and they were kind of like don't
worry president we're gonna do our duty
we're gonna open up a can of whoop ass
on the great Satan and we kind of
self-deficated with the United States
watching it was well it set the game
back decades how big would this be if
the United States beats England
um for to get in for the game of
football in the in the United States a
game of dreams and yearning I moved here
in 1994
um the World Cup then that was here was
meant to put football over the top in
this nation overnight because we like
overnight things in America you know the
yo-yo the pogo stick instead it's been a
slow and steady grind if this young team
were to beat America even the the even
what just you mentioning it Dan Patrick
in Dan Patrick's accent well I look at
you in the eye it gives me shivers it's
the it would be the thing because the
women the women are World beaters back
to back the United States women have
been one of the great drivers the group
for the game I love in the nation I love
if the United States men beat Mighty
England who just won 6-2 against Iran it
would possibly be the thing that would
make the game go having said that I've
just used a phrase that was used by the
one single journalist in 1950 when the
United States
um a gay a team of like there was an
Undertaker playing for us we had a minor
league baseball catcher we had I mean it
was just an amateur amateur team of
duffers beat the mighty England 1950 we
won one nil a movie game of Our Lives
was made about it and the coach after
that said this win is all we need to
make the game go in America and no one
turned up at the airport to greet them
when they came out to many full stones
and anyway Dan it's a massive if it's a
massive if I know by the way uh in case
you're not able to watch what Roger has
he's got a Montreal Expos hat on
you have uh Tracy Chapman album behind
you I believe yeah sadness is always
lingering behind every door that's a
reminder whenever you're too happy in
life your water Peyton painting behind
you oh what a legend the great greatest
the one of the reasons I'm in America
the Super Bowl Bears winning team 1985.
what else did you say that American flag
yeah lots of them I told you I rode with
Team USA now you beautiful human being
um
okay what would happen if england would
get roughed up what would it be like in
England if the United States roughs up
England let's say two nil
God I love this conversation this is
just like you're taking me to my happy
place it would be look here's the
reality so American Sports You Love
winners it's part of the reason that
there's a certain shame and a certain
stigma but we don't want to truly trust
our men because they we know they're
gonna possibly let us down we like
winners we like Charles Barkley rising
up over and angolan uh hapless Defender
when we're already 70 points up Donkey
on them and elbowing him in the head we
love that that's what we love Yeah and
our soccer team do not do that and the
world knows how men's soccer team don't
do that and that's why this joke about
soccer or football where they take the
piss out of us for using the word soccer
here by the way when they use the word
soccer quite freely over in England two
of the biggest shows on English
television are soccer Saturday as a long
running Saturday television show and
soccer a.m a morning they use the word
but they laugh when we use it because
they know that we know that they know
that we have an inferiority complex and
World Loves America we don't have much
where do we have much of an inferiority
complex so if we were to be England the
shame for that Nation they'd say oh
they've taken that one thing away that
we had on them soccer football it's the
one thing that we all had on them and
they've taken that away and we took
Adele we took the Beatles we you know
Rebecca hello we took Cordon now we're
giving him back we don't want James
Gordon back we gave him back and we got
Beckham Beckham's hours now is he he's
having a complicated moment Beckham I
think Beckham Hank Beckham is partially
Qatari at this point I'm not quite sure
what part of his identity he's doing a
lot of spice marketing he's doing a lot
did you say partially or partially
[Applause]
I don't know which on it is it's quite
it's quite a thing in England where he's
been waiting for a Knighthood for a long
time which is not coming he's taken a
lot of money to become an ambassador
wait they knighthooded they they
knighted uh Nick Faldo
a great the great Nick Felder I don't
know you're asking me how knighthoods
were
shouldn't Bex be knighted yeah when the
queen died
um
and she had a crush on him she probably
had a crush on him you can't you right
this is a Rebecca Louie series of
questions because when the queen died I
got asked to do a lot of Television like
can you come on and talk about the
morning and I was like honestly I have
no idea about any of that so I came here
to America to get away from all that
crap so the the Knighthood stuff other
people can expect yeah I love that
you're coming at me with the Nick Faldo
got one I don't know how it works I just
know that you will not be getting one
that I won't be getting one maybe Fritz
will get one I have no idea how this
crap works have a great weekend God I
hope so I hope so I hope so we've got to
tell you who we're watching we're
watching the show live on Twitch with
the game with Matthew McConaughey so um
that could make for a great opening 45
minutes it could be a very dark very
dark last 45 but God sweetie go go USA
right all right all right
thank you Roger if that is the men in
Blazers even though I was not wearing a
Blazer he had a Montreal Expos hat on
there Roger Bennett